avec l'aggravation de la situation en
ukraine et les multiples sanctions
imposées à la russie de vladimir poutine
l'europe toute entière s'est retrouvé
face à une réalité cette sortie de notre
dépendance au pétrole et au gaz russe
passe là aussi par une diversification
de nos achats et un pays pourrait sortir
son épingle du jeu dans cette crise les
états de
grâce aux énergies et à d'autres
éléments que nous allons vous dévoiler
dans cette vidéo on va voir dans facture
comme on les états unis pourraient
bénéficier de la guerre en crée
ce graphique représente les importations
en gaz de l'europe en 2019 le gaz russe
représente et 44 % du mix énergétique du
continent
parmi les nombreuses sanctions contre la
russie pour faire cesser le conflit en
ukraine on entend réduire la dépendance
au gaz russe dans le mix énergétique de
l'ue eux
pour répondre au nom qu'à venir des 27
joe biden se place en rempart face à la
russie - a repris 2 606 machine gâchage
pourquoi est ce proche chacun
[Musique]
la commission européenne a annoncé
vouloir acheter 15 milliards de giga
mètres cubes de gaz naturel liquéfié gnl
un premier pas vers les états unis qui
devraient donc à terme permettre de
supprimer le gaz russe de la
consommation européenne
c'est une opportunité pour à court terme
dans l'est dans l'année qui vient dans
les deux années qui viennent et
effectivement prendre des parts de
marché à l'acteur historique de la
fourniture de gaz et d'hydrocarbures en
europe c'est-à-dire la fédération de
russie ça vient renforcer leur rôle ils
bien et renforcer leur influence et leur
prédominance et qu'ils sommes bien sûr
au niveau diplomatique au niveau
économique et maintenant avec ce conflit
énergétique
à ce stade l'accord soulève deux
problèmes en premier écologique puisque
d'après cette étude publiée par carbone
le gnl en provenance des états unis
aurait un impact carbone devient que
cinq fois plus élevé que le gaz russe
un deuxième de stocks étant donné que ce
marché ne dépend pas exclusivement de la
maison blanche mais surtout de
l'industrie et que les états unis sont
déjà engagés auprès d'autres pays
étrangers comme en asie
la question est surtout de savoir
comment ils pourront subvenir aux
besoins de tous est le pétrole russe
avait certes un avantage que les
nouveaux fournisseurs en termes de
substitution non pas encore à mon sens
ce qui est plus important à retenir
c'est le signal le signal envoyé c'est
de dire pas moyen à long terme nous ne
serons plus dépendants de la russie et
nous aurons d'autres fournisseurs dont
les états unis qui sont un fournisseur
privilégié et donc un allié également
économiques diplomatiques cette
indépendance énergétique permet donc aux
états unis de se placer comme un associé
considérable de l'europe et l'aspect
financier elle est lui aussi à titre
d'exemple berlin à débloquer 1,5
milliard d'euros pour acheter du gel et
notamment aux américains
le gaz n'est pas le seul marché que les
états unis pourraient rafler il y à
aussi l'alimentation et notamment le blé
[Musique]
si on se penche sur ces chiffres on
constate que la russie et l'ukraine se
placent respectivement à la première et
à la cinquième place du classement
mondial
encore une fois avec les sanctions
imposées à la russie et la guerre qui
fait rage en ukraine le prix du blé a
augmenté de façon exponentielle
faisant passer son prix de 200 euros la
tonne en avril 2021 à 400 euros la tonne
aujourd'hui une aubaine pour les
américains comme souligné par ce rapport
de l'usda le département de
l'agriculture des états unis la demande
de l'union européenne est également en
hausse car le continent n'est pas en
mesure de s'approvisionner en
importations en provenance d'ukraine et
seuls les états unis deuxième dans le
classement des exportations mondiales de
blé pour ont majoritairement y répondre
[Musique]
qui d'autre que le pays à la plus grande
armée du monde pourrait répondre aux
besoins grandissants du vieux continent
qui fait face à une guerre à ses portes
une remarque qui a également été
analysée par la folle tu vas
me demba fall of democracy ned faymann a
récemment l'allemagne encore une fois a
décidé de débloquer 100 milliards
d'euros pour moderniser son armée bien
que l'europe compte de nombreuses
industries d'armement c'est vers les
américains à nouveau que notre voisin
européen a choisi de se tourner la gare
en ukraine a pressé l'allemagne de miser
essentiellement sur les f-35 ses avions
de combat de l'armée américaine
confiance stratégique européenne s'est
réveillé c'est un point très positif et
les vieux réflexes otaniens de
fourniture d'armement auprès des états
unis se sont réveillés et ça c'est
peut-être une moins bonne nouvelle pour
l'autonomie stratégique européenne c'est
assurément une très bonne nouvelle pour
les grands groupes d'armement et de
défense américain
sur l'aspect financier washington aura
donc saisi l'opportunité stratégique qui
s'est offert tél suite au conflit russo
ukrainien
mais vous l'aurez compris ce n'est pas
le seul avantage qu'ont acquis les états
unis pour qui cette crise leur permettra
également d'élargir et surtout confirmer
leur puissance à courte et change bien
sûr qu'une influence des etats unis sera
renforcée à tous points de vue en europe
occidentale et en europe orientale mais
à plus longue échéance
les etats-unis ne seront pas
nécessairement les principaux gagnants
de ces ce changement dans les relations
internationales en europe les européens
sont lents mais quand ils construisent
ils construisent de façon solide et
durable